le prix nobel de littérature a été
attribué à la polonaise donc olga
tokarczuk pour l'année 2018 faut dire
que la remise du prix avait été reportée
d'un an après un scandale d'agression
sexuelle au sein de l'institution
suédoise le nobel 2019 lui ai remis à
l'autrichien peter annick et claudia
larochelle est là pour nous en dire plus
à propos de ces deux lauréats qui se
sont fait connaître par seulement à
cause de leur littérature
bonsoir à claudia en cierge à dire
comment son parlez nous de la polonaise
dont on connaît tous qu'un choc au web
ont écouté elle a 57 ans c'est l'une des
fervente opposante à l'actuel
gouvernement polonais nationalistes de
droite
exactement c'est une femme qui très très
impliqué dans les causes sociales s
impliquent pour un milite pour le droit
des animaux et les féministes elle est
engagé dans les causes environnementales
aussi très politique très politisée et
ses oeuvres en sont teintés de ses
réflexions la wii alors c'est vraiment
une femme qui tombe quand on donne un
nobel comme ça elle sait le nobel donc
2018 quand on récompense un écrivain ou
une écrivaine il faut penser que c'est
vraiment l'ensemble de l'oeuvre qu'on
récompense qu'on salue et pas seulement
un livre en particulier ou un titre en
particulier alors l'académie a salué une
imagination narrative qui avec une
passion encyclopédique représente le
franchissement des frontières et les
connu en pologne c'est une star là bas
elle est traduite dans 25 langues
on lui connaît le roman sur les
ossements des morts porté à l'écran en
2017 par la réalisatrice agnès car
hollande alors sous le titre pokot tous
peur en anglais et son thriller parce
qu'elle fait beaucoup de thriller aussi
on lui reconnaît les livres de jacob
dieu le temps les hommes et les anges
d'ailleurs geneviève d'une citation
magnifique très songé à tirer du
livre le livre de jacob alors je vais
l'histoire de dissidents jupe ou 18 et
cliquer directement
dieu a créé créé l'homme avec les yeux
par devant et pas à l'arrière de la tête
ce qui veut dire que l'homme doit
s'occuper de ce qui vient et pas ceux de
ce qui a été libre de jacob intéressant
une je pense qu'elle a étudié en
psychologie vont s'ouvrir à la
littérature parlez nous maintenant de
monsieur anouk et alors le nobel 2019
lui a été remis il a 76 ans est depuis
ses débuts en 1963 lui il a publié une
quarantaine de reproducteurs très
prolifique dans tous les genres
littéraires un peu plus controversées
que tout parte chaud que je dirais même
sur les réseaux sociaux je suis allé
voir avant de venir
il déclenche un peu plus les polémiques
et qui est moins on dirait que le les
gens sont moins de six mois une
animation demain oui c'est peut-être lié
à ces à ses prises de position
politiques aussi
et donc mais on lui reprochait souvent
d'être pro serbe d'avoir dont il s'est
présenté en 2006 aux funérailles de les
soulever le génocidaire de l'ex
yougoslavie
voilà souvent on est revenus contre lui
à ce sujet là ce qui ne change pas selon
moi la qualité de son oeuvre d'ailleurs
le l'académie lui a salué son travail
influents qui avec son ingéniosité
linguistique à explorer la périphérie et
l'aspect civil spécifiant cité de
l'expérience humaine
alors c'est vraiment une oeuvre un style
il le fait éclater la forme aussi
adressé début mai
alors on connaît aussi son travail avec
avec wenders le réalisateur il s'est
impliqué réduit le scénariste de l'ale
les ailes du désir de compenser saluée
par tous par la critique à l'horizon
comme eux tous les deux que d'avoir eu
des oeuvres porter une partie de
l'oeuvre porté à l'écran
oui et ça ça signifie beaucoup
ça signifie qu'on a essayé donc d'aller
parce que là la faut dire qu'avec la
contreverse je pense qu'on essaie d'être
assis rassembleur on a essayé de
s'éloigner des controverses la polémique
le pen qui est un peu plus ils ont un
peu plus chaud mais quand même donc on
est allé vers des sujets des livres qui
peut être effectivement avait été servi
de référence dans dans l'est dans
l'oreille des gens aussi donc il ya ça
et c'est aussi des gens qui ont une
plume je dirais très ils sont habiles
dans tous les genres dans tous les
styles dans la poésie les essais
heynckes ont un grand essayez ceci il ya
touché au scénario évidemment s'est fait
connaître pour les ailes du désir mais
pour d'autres films sublime ses traits
sont j'ai aussi et ses hommes tout comme
celle des tocards tschupp sont très
ancrés dans la réalité dans l'actualité
aussi et c'est aussi ce que le nobel
salut ne faut pas oublier que le nobel
et c'est de saluer des oeuvres qui sont
ancrés dans le réel dans ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à travers la planète à
travers le monde
d'où le choix notamment de tokarczuk
avec l'environnement avec le droit des
années
tout ça donc ces choix là est évidemment
là ils vont recevoir leur prix vont
faire leurs discours ils vont vendre des
livres encore et encore ils seront
traduits c'est vraiment des tout grands
honneurs pour eux alors une invitation à
la lecture merci beaucoup
j'avais un plaisir fou